12 jours sans eau ni nourriture coincée
sous une tonne de débris cet homme a
survécu
sa femme et leur fils ont aussi été
extirpé des décombres
malgré les efforts toutes nues des
secouristes l'enfant n'a pas survécu
comme sa grande sœur et son frère jumeau
une petite famille décimée par ce séisme
dévastateur survenu il y a près de deux
semaines maintenant
sur le terrain les recherches dans les
débris se poursuivent mais la tâche pour
retrouver des corps et colossales
n'est pas comme lorsqu'il y a un
accident les corps sont ensevelis sous
des montagnes de débris pendant ce temps
diazine les familles attendent
les parents ne devrait pas enterrer
leurs enfants ajoute-t-il
parmi les visages de la tragédie celui
du joueur de ce cœur professionnel
Christian en dessous 31 ans au moment du
séisme il était dans sa résidence un
appartement de luxe dans une tour de 12
étages il pourrait y avoir 800 personnes
sous les décombres le promoteur
responsable de la construction a été
arrêté alors qu'il tentait de fuir la
Turquie
pendant ce temps dans ce cimetière de
Caraman Maras les pierres tombales
s'ajoutent par milliers le bilan
pourrait encore grimper on estime que
plus de 250 000 logements ont été
détruits dans le séisme ici qui me
permettra au Canada Montréal
[Musique]